S
FOLLOWING A MASS SHOOTING IN A
NASHVILLE ELEMENTARY SCHOOL. AND
ON FRIDAY, TWO FEDERAL JUDGES
SPLIT OVER THE FUTURE OF THE
MEDICATION. ABORTION DRUG
MIFEPRISTONE, A JUDGE IN TEXAS
GAVE THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
SEVEN DAYS TO APPEAL HIS
DECISION, WHICH BLOCKED THE FDA
IS APPROVAL OF THE WIDELY USED
ABORTION DRUG, THROWING MANY
WOMEN AND MEDICAL PROVIDERS INTO
A STATE OF CERTAINTY. HERE WITH
ME NOW IS THE SECRETARY OF
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES.
JAVIER BECERRA. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR COMING IN THIS MORNING
. SO THIS TEXAS RULING BANNING
MEDFORD CRESTONE GOES INTO
EFFECT ON FRIDAY UNLESS THE STAY
IS ISSUED THE QUESTION THAT
WOMEN ACROSS AMERICA HAVE RIGHT
NOW IS WILL THEY HAVE ACCESS TO
ABORTION MEDICATION AFTER THIS
WEEK? WELL THEY CERTAINLY HAVE
ACCESS TODAY AND WE INTEND TO DO
EVERYTHING TO MAKE SURE IT'S
AVAILABLE TO THEM NOT JUST IN A
WEEK BUT MOVING FORWARD PERIOD
BECAUSE MIFID KRISTEN IS ONE OF
THE SAFEST AND MOST EFFECTIVE
MEDICINES THAT WE'VE SEEN OVER
THE LAST 20 YEARS TO HELP WOMEN
WITH WITH THEIR HEALTH CARE,
ESPECIALLY ABORTION CARE. SO UH,
IT IS INCUMBENT UPON US AS A
COUNTRY. TO MAKE SURE WOMEN HAVE
SAFE AND EFFECTIVE MEDICATION
AVAILABLE TO DO THAT. WELL WE'VE
ALREADY FILED AN APPEAL OF THIS
COURT'S RULING. ONE JUDGE IN ONE
COURT IN ONE STATE. TURNED
UPSIDE DOWN. THE FDA IS APPROVAL
PROCESS FOR SAFE AND EFFECTIVE
MEDICATIONS. WE HAVE TO GO TO
COURT AND SEEK AN APPEAL. WHAT
HAPPENS IF THE BAN IS UPHELD?
WILL THIS DRUG DISAPPEAR FROM
THE MARKET MARKET OVERNIGHT? SO
THAT'S DANA. THAT'S BIG
SPECULATION. FIRST AND FOREMOST
WHEN YOU TURN UPSIDE DOWN THE
ENTIRE FDA APPROVAL PROCESS
YOU'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT JUST
MISS MITFORD CRISTO. YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT EVERY KIND OF DRUG
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT OUR
VACCINES. YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
INSULIN. YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
THE NEW ALZHEIMER'S DRUGS THAT
MAY COME ON. IF A JUDGE DECIDES
TO SUBSTITUTE HIS PREFERENCES,
PERSONAL OPINION FOR THAT OF
SCIENTISTS AND MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS. WHAT DRUG ISN'T
SUBJECT TO SOME KIND OF LEGAL
CHALLENGE, SO WE HAVE TO GO TO
COURT AND FOR AMERICA'S SAKE AND
FOR WOMEN'S SAKE WE HAVE TO. WE
HAVE TO PREVAIL IN THIS. MY NEXT
GUEST, DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSWOMAN
ALEXANDRIA, CASIO. CORTES THINKS
THAT THE FDA SHOULD JUST IGNORE
THE TEXAS JUDGE'S RULING. AND
YOU KNOW SHE'S NOT ALONE. I'M
SURE YOU'VE SEEN SOME LEGAL
EXPERTS ARGUED THE FDA DOES HAVE
BROAD DISCRETION. TO SIMPLY
CHOOSE NOT TO ENFORCE A BAN AND
ALLOW THE DRUG TO REMAIN ON THE
MARKET. SO YES OR NO AS THE HHS
SECRETARY, DO YOU WANT THE FDA
TO ENFORCE THE TEXAS RULING IF
IT IS UPHELD? IN THE SHORT TERM
. YES OR NO. WE WANT THE COURTS
TO OVERTURN THIS RECKLESS
DECISION. YES OR NO? WE WANT YES
THAT WOMEN CONTINUE TO HAVE
ACCESS TO A DRUG THAT'S PROVEN
ITSELF SAFE. MILLIONS OF WOMEN
HAVE USED THIS DRUG AROUND
AROUND THE WORLD FOR THE 60
COUNTRIES. BUT WHAT IF THEY
DON'T ACT IN THE INTERIM BEFORE
YOU GET TO THAT POINT TO BELIEVE
THAT AN APPEALS COURT THE
SUPREME COURT, WHATEVER COURT
HAS TO UNDERSTAND THAT THIS
RULING BY THIS ONE. JUDGE
OVERTURNS NOT JUST ACCESS TO
MIFID KRISTEN, BUT POSSIBLY ANY
NUMBER OF DRUGS. WHAT IF THEY
DON'T? THAT SPECULATION THAT I
THINK IS NOT WORTH ENGAGING IN.
ARE YOU TAKING IT OFF THE TABLE
THAT YOU WILL RECOMMEND THE FDA
IGNORE? A BAN. EVERYTHING IS ON
THE TABLE. THE PRESIDENT SAID
THAT WAY BACK WHEN THE DOBBS
DECISION CAME OUT, EVERY OPTION
IS ON THE TABLE. SO I WANT TO
ASK ABOUT THE SUPREME COURT
BECAUSE YOU OBVIOUSLY SEE THIS.
YOU HOPE THAT YOU WIN AN APPEAL.
IT WILL LIKELY GO TO THE SUPREME
COURT. DO YOU AGREE WITH THAT?
GOOD CHANCE. SO HOW WORRIED ARE
YOU THAT THIS COURT CONSERVATIVE
MAJORITY IN THE UNITED STATES
SUPREME COURT WILL AGREE WITH
THE TEXAS JUDGE. IF THE ROLE OF
JUDGES AND JUSTICES IS TO APPLY
THE LAW TO THE FACTS AND THE
EVIDENCE, THE FACTS AND THE
SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE ARE THAT
MEDFORD. KRISTEN IS NOT JUST
SAFE, BUT IT'S EFFECTIVE AND IT
WAS PROPERLY APPROVED. AND SO I
DON'T CARE WHO THE NIGHT
JUSTICES ON THE SUPREME COURT OR
ANY COURT OF APPEAL. THEY SHOULD
BE ABLE TO DISCERN THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN INSERTING
THEIR PERSONAL JUDGMENT AND
USING THE FACTS AND EVIDENCE TO
MAKE A LEGAL RULING. DO YOU FEEL
CONFIDENT THAT COULD HAPPEN WITH
THIS COURT. I DO, BUT I'M NOT ON
THE COURTS, AND CERTAINLY I'M
NOT ON THAT COURT WHERE THAT
TEXAS JUDGE DECIDED TO, UH, TURN
UPSIDE DOWN THE WHOLE PROCESS
THAT FDA YOU HAS USED FOR YEARS
. FOR MANY DRUGS. WE ARE NOW IN
A PERIOD OF UNCERTAINTY LIKE
THIS WEEK. WHAT'S YOUR MESSAGE
TO WOMEN AND TO MEDICAL
PROVIDERS WHO WANT TO GET THIS
DRUG AND USE THIS DRUG? THIS IS
NOT AMERICA. WHAT YOU SAW BY
THAT ONE JUDGE IN THAT ONE COURT
IN THAT ONE STATE THAT'S NOT
AMERICA. AMERICA GOES BY THE
EVIDENCE AMERICA DOES WHAT'S
FAIR